it's a piece of walking down a trail of
leaving crumbs to find his way home I
can't keep track of home brian Stelter
it doesn't matter the neighbor
here's the thing it's a slow nothing
about this is going to be good no it's
all accurate but it's very awfully much
like brian Stelter so this is long
overdue for brian Stelter but the past
few weeks he's really earned it with the
leftist propaganda he's been pushing and
it's even more you know what it's just
it's time for this week's what a
piece-of-shit way to reach into the wall
yeah yeah reach into the vault to find
that picture
do you have Brian stoked you don't have
him in case that what he really looks
like a real person is a real person on
the new he has his own show yes
disgusting ok so reason number 5 and
this is what bothers me most I know this
should probably number one but I think
it sets up the context most importantly
this guy brian Stelter is constantly and
he doesn't even see how transparent it
is it's inadvertently transparent he's
not trying to be transparent
he's accidentally transparent in
praising his own show his own network
he's constantly Trey's whole show it's
just about convincing you of his value
as a media dinosaur here you go
and I'm actually a defender of this
cable talk-show model I'm an avid viewer
of it course you are because news
headlines are ubiquitous these days our
phones alert us for the news so cable is
more like a rolling talk show letting
people be a part of the daily debate
about how our country should be governed
and how our world should work but here's
the thing speculation actually has value
to it helps open our eyes helps open our
minds to what's possible I know people
like to mock cable news at moments like
this it's an easy punchline right we are
kind of standing by to find out what the
news is gonna be waiting for AG bar to
tell us something nothing but that does
have value to know gives you a place to
go a place to turn to
a recognition that you're not the only
one who wants to know go read an online
article go home go to the pub and get
crap face anything but this yes it has
value to complete speculation devoid of
sex what a piece of you you brian
Stelter you use your airtime to advocate
why you need the remaining portion of
your unit ID by the way did you know pen
tell us he's he's straight for a
relocking penis though he lacks last
credits now you think you'd have more
they think you feel a little more
whimsical yes brian Stelter you
generally don't get the story right you
nearly always get it wrong and then you
double down don't believe me yet well
we're gonna get two reasons for through
one you pieces so let's go reason number
four I should have had a language
warning it's bleeped but this is
designed with it in mind but I just
there's no other way to just Jessie
small it and brian Stelter and I know
he's gonna see this you're welcome ah he
blamed the synagogue shooting okay this
is reason number four
blaming synagogue shooting on fox news
anchors here you go the ridiculousness
of this rhetoric but it is effective
among some people i sir hope some of
those Fox hosts some of those
commentators take a moment take a minute
to think about their role in this
environment hopefully there's some
soul-searching right now in the wake of
this massacre what what does that do the
silent seekers he's like if we had more
immigrants they could shield the Jew
what is he talking about but you will
notice a trend as we go through these
clips
he's the news correspondent equivalent
of Christian Bale he's all occur within
the same year it's like guess his weight
step right up step back to Thanksgiving
see so still to here you argued that Fox
News referred to immigrants as invaders
and that the somehow drove someone to
shoot I guess a bunch of a bunch of Jews
that's what he's trying to say Fox News
is responsible for shooting Jews
Mohammed by the way not responsible for
anyone having sex with six-year-old
girls or you know killing Jews as in
call for his last words that would be a
misinterpretation of kill the Jew
insensitive how's the smear campaign yes
definitely
campaign from big hadith yeah okay how
about this call me when CNN when you do
a segment mr. Stelter on how ill Anoma
or Linda Sarsour they're responsible for
any crimes against you so let's just you
know people say it's not fair to compare
Muhammad okay current figures but Brian
I don't think you will that would
require you to be consistent which you
most never are and is ironically one of
the strong suits of most pieces of so
it's as though you've missed the boat
even on that by the way hit the
notification bell if you're subscribed
on YouTube because subscriptions want me
a whole lot anymore also bookmark the
page because notifications may not work
anymore let us know if you're getting
them best thing is to join a lot of
credit comm slash mug Club you get the
full catalog full daily show and of
course subscribe on iTunes and rate us
there because we might be pulled who
knows okay what is it number three this
one should I mean I almost could just
roll the clip but let me just set it up
and play it for people who are listening
in the presidential candidate seriously
repeatedly here you go
President Obama also had a lot of TV
star power and that helped him pre Trump
but Trump it's more evidence of this and
looking at the 2020 one reason why I'm
taking you seriously as a contender is
because of your presence on cable news
really put a black Garrett soundboard
hit that that one needs that's a big
that seems like a prime Stelter one he
would blame it on the dog but not like
as a joke that's cute like it's the dog
he'd be like no it's seriously the dog I
think we need to put it down to cover up
his own trauma to the vet and have the
dog put down just so he wouldn't be
blamed he with everybody who's
specifically totally taking him
seriously because of his appearances on
CNN they can't go back to reason but I
think that you'll be a great president
because I want to remain employed and
you're on my show that means you're
important wouldn't be on my show all
wrong it's cuz he likes his hair
there's a million camaraderie there by
the way the only reason to have an ID
was because over a hundred times in ten
weeks a hundred times in ten weeks if
you want to this is kind of like what
bill bill maher said uh if I want to
know the Trump colluded with the
Russians I just turn on my TV I have I
see yourself yes
saying it this is like brian Stelter
saying the reason have an i it would be
great is because he's on all of the
important shows well which shows my show
he's on my show therefore you should be
president so it could be on more shows
when he's president which shows my show
i think he should be on my show so it
becomes president so it comes back on my
show completely 100 percent straight by
it what does that go-getter of an IT up
to now who himself is equally a piece of
now been arrested for trying to extort
nike for fifty million dollars he's
taking one of those prison readiness
classes right yes here's what you do and
when he went in to put his belongings in
the been he said wait haven't you seen
me on Stelter and they said sir
no one's seen you on this but he does
come in every few weeks for voluntary
conjugal visits he just wants to hold a
smile on their face ah reason number two
he blamed it at the female prisons
clearly right okay yes i'm really not
just weaponizing sexuality here of
course I had my to everyone in this room
honestly okay if you were to watch that
would you take the guy straight I would
have questions well you're the worst
gaydar in the world Pantelis madoski I
didn't think he was a person reason
number two if this one's pretty obvious
he blamed Rutan the Russia right that he
blamed Donald Trump for the Russian
collusion conspiracy that would seem bad
enough but here's the thing that's
actually not number two here all right
he actually blamed the conspiracy itself
on Trump
so after Stelter was pushing the
narrative for two years on his show
because speculation is super important
and then it was completely blown up he
doesn't apologize he blames the
conspiracy for being created by Trump
here you're gonna hear this from the
right for the next days and weeks
to come the depresses basically made all
this up to take down President Trump but
the press is just following a trail that
Trump created so closeted journalists
were following a trail that Trump create
what it led to nowhere like Donald Trump
like this is like okay this is gonna be
one of the greatest tricks of political
history all right they're gonna hang
this around by deck and it's gonna
impede my presidency I was gonna get
impeached take this field I see for
example it was a fake document created
by a Democrat PR firm the meet you
spread and by the way don't he went on
to say that the rush of collusion and it
was basically the entire premise of the
show by the way named reliable sources
on anok all day watch this clip welcome
back to reliable sources where everyday
we're trying to keep track of the drip
drip drip of the Russia investigation
something else it's a piece of walking
down a trail of leaving crumbs to find
his way home I can't keep track of all
this I mean he's really trying to cut it
off at the past and he just doesn't know
how no no listen they're gonna say that
the Russian collusion thing is not true
that it didn't happen but these the same
people who don't believe I'm straight
also Donald Trump was the one who did
this Donald Trump was the one who set
the trail of breadcrumbs when Roger
stone met with Russians and sent a tweet
to Julian Assange and by the way what
was Donald Trump doing when he had a kid
rock out an American flag pens so at one
point had sex with cable anderson who
happens to be friends once again Julian
Assange why are you leaving it's
practically a bakery president Ron what
oh no you're gonna blame me now I used
to reinvent himself he's gonna shove it
completely ooh tattoo guitars and flames
called self helter-skelter
yeah that was that [ __ ] will suck too
though really will reason number one
honestly the sick joke by and they don't
really need to go in this order but just
because he was also in our previous pls
segment defending Jesse Smollett now
again it's not just about the Jesse
Smollett hate crime being exposes a hoax
um that would be too reductive we
wouldn't want to be reductive when
addressing brian Stelter because he
brian Stelter i think of him as a
nuanced issue you know like a bridge
troll so he claimed like they're not all
bad everybody else
he claimed that news organizations were
really careful oh and then it was own so
this is what it's not just that he
rushed to judgment he claimed that the
news didn't rush it was only random
people on twitter who rush to judgment
there was a rush to judgment i think it
was mostly in the celebrity press and
among activists and among twitter people
i think it was a really careful
reporting by news organizations but it
all gets lumped in together at the end
of the day it all gets lumped together
in the minds of many people
wrong again from Brooke Baldwin
to April right I think you've Don Lemon
no yes absolutely Don Lemon he actively
helped to push the small at hoax and how
do you know that we're telling the truth
because now Stelter is claiming even
today that we may never know what
happened on that fateful night the
narrative is once again changed from
victim you know to villain back to
victim it's been very confusing that the
line was saying people don't know what
to believe and we may never really know
what happened on the street that night
in Chicago well I guess it remains a
mystery to all of us satting off good
night and I'm a piece of [ __ ] he's
confused by on and off switches okay by
the way so we may never know okay let me
kind of rattle off why that might not be
true okay the DA specifically said that
small it was guilty you were just
letting him off because he served 16
hours of community service we have video
of the Nigerian brothers purchasing the
materials using the attack we have a
testimony that Jesse paid them and we
have the check with which he actually
paid them this story didn't have a turd
in the punchbowl from the beginning
the whole punch bowl was nothing but he
wrote a memo line fake attack ha ha able
to fake checks cash then made this
decision
the reason brian Stelter has he gets to
go out to continually advocate for his
job right really he has to he doesn't
just have a portion of his show watch
his show this is my challenge to you I'm
sorry but watch his show and tell me if
he goes a single segment without somehow
advocating for the importance of his job
and he has to do it because of the blind
spot that networks like CNN have they
have to I don't please someone tell me
fat yep check talentless yep seemingly
gay check uninteresting yep no one will
watch check you have a show sir they
realize you were he's proof positive
about the blind spot immediate they
actually thought his show would work
someone someone lost to brian Stelter
there was a callback imagine being in
that room there's people sitting there
with their sides at the callback and
they're all everyone there right they're
nervous but they all feel pretty
confident that he's not gonna get it
they're pointing to shelter and then
they see him on television later that
week and they say no that's how bad and
how much of a piece of I think is if you
think I'm out of line please let me know
hey there Here I am drinking from my mug
in a button-down how often do you see
this never so do me a favor and yourself
click one of these videos playing in one
of these boxes here or a subscribe hit a
notification bell also because
subscriptions don't really mean a whole
lot if you really want to support the
show join my club if you don't then
there's no helping you